tell me his name again is MIA and Bing
TCF everybody let's go in this demon
we're gonna need some help
your adventure now they listed only
their soul a stance was my name the
Avengers man of some ideas heroes a
veritable
Avengers infinity war plus if you get up
a hitter to see Tony Stark
feed your health in five days
that house is covered you sure you're up
to this
walk them
me personally I give us a lot nothing
can prepare you for the cinematic event
of a lifetime
[Music]
it's already leave news
Avengers infinity war wicked pg-13
everywhere Friday Tony Stark need your
help in five days
dad us is gone you sure you're up to
this
me personally I give us love nothing can
prepare you for the cinematic event of a
lifetime
it's always leaving us
Avengers infinity war rated pg-13
everywhere Friday
five days solemnly knows where will you
be when destiny arrives join us we're in
so cool Avengers infinity war who the
pg-13 everywhere Friday you're strong
but I could snap my fingers and it all
cease to exist
[Applause]
and tour in time to see all the possible
outcomes
did we win any
it's a small price to pay
to salvation
[Music]
[Music]
we don't want to kill you
oh we will tell me his name again
Thanos he's a plague Tony he invades
planets he takes what he wants he wipes
out half the population
he said Loki the attack on New York
that's him what's her timeline
no telling he has the power and space
stones that already makes him the
strongest creature in the whole universe
if he gets his hands on all six dollars
Tony he could destroy life on a scale
hitherto on dreamt on did you seriously
just say hitherto on drunk doesn't
seriously leaning on the cauldron of the
cosmos never that I'm going to allow
then if Thanos taint so six why don't we
just stick this one down the garbage
disposal no can do we swore an oath to
protect the time stone with our lives
and I swore off dairy then injuries
named a flavor after me so stark raving
hazelnuts not been shocked
[Music]
[Music]
the structure is polymorphic right we
had to attach each neuron non non
sequential why didn't you just reprogram
the synapses to work collectively
because we didn't think of it I'm sure
you did you abyss in 10 days destinies
here or should I say I am where will you
be when it all ends I hope there
remember Avengers infinity war [ __ ]
pg-13
you